i think a lot of people would be curious  to see a fight between you and khabib  what do you think about all these  conversations coming up to see the two  of you guys fight well it's uh  it's always a question of timing we  we've tried to make it happen  when i retired  a year after i retired we approached the  ufc with that idea  and khabib was on board i was on board  but the ufc had other plan they wanted  to  did in a business point of view it makes  sense because i wanted to keep kebab  active  because they keep the ball rolling  they knew that if  it would i would only come back for  maybe one fight you know what i mean  um they rather  keep  active i guess and not taking the risk  and i understand that  and therefore that's why i believe it  did not materialize